improve your react skills by learning to
build a dictionary app
in this course from roadside coder the
dictionary uses material ui
and supports 12 languages hey everyone
welcome back to free code camp and today
we are going to build an awesome
dictionary
app using react.js and material ui so
this video has two sections
in the first one we are going to build
and deploy this app on netlify and in
the second section we will convert it
into a pwa or progressive web app so
that you can install this app as a
native android or ios app into your
phone
so let's explore this app first
so this dictionary has support of over
12 languages
let's search a word real quick let's
search plane
now you can see it provides the
definition example
and the synonym for that particular word
and not only one definition it provides
all the definition of that particular
word and what's even better
is this pronunciation audio you can play
this
plane it tells you the pronunciation of
that particular word
so yeah that's awesome and i guess just
pronunciation is uh supported in english
only
so let's go to hindi language and i'm
going to search my name which is
push and here you go you have the
meaning of this particular name
so this is an amazing app now what's
better in this app
is you see in this little corner over
here
ta-da light mode and dark mode here's
that's
amazing feature of this app you can
implement it by using material ui
as well so i'm that's why i've chosen
material ui because it's so easy to
implement this dark mode and light mode
feature in material ui
also if you're interested in more
tutorials on react.js be sure to check
out my channel which is called roadside
coder
recently i have uploaded a full-fledged
merge stack project tutorial with redux
on my channel link will be in the
description below
so without any further ado let's get
started
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
open a new project real quick let me
select my folder
i'm gonna go over here and select this
particular folder
i mean let me close these files real
quick yeah
so we need to go to our terminal and
type
npx create react
app and we're gonna name this app we're
gonna name this app
word hunt oops i made a mistake
let me correct this npm to npx and press
enter now what it's going to do it's
going to go to the
npm repository it's going to take all of
the files needed to create our create
react app
and going to bring them over into this
word hunt folder
so meanwhile this is initializing let me
just show you the api
that we're going to use for this app so
the api that we're going to use is
called
google dictionary api this is an
unofficial google dictionary api
created by this guy me developer thank
you so much me developer for this api
so this api provides us these support of
these many languages and how are we
going to use this api
we're going to provide a language code
to this api
and a particular word so it's going to
go
and fetch data in this form
so we're gonna we're gonna see how we
can deal with this data later
so you can see we have a language
support over here with over these many
languages english hindi spanish french
etc
a lot of languages over here this is a
amazing api
so yeah also let's explore
material ui real quick so what is
materially why
material ui is a react components for
faster and easier web development
it's a react component library now what
is a react component library
so react component library is something
which provides you with
pre-built uh you know pre-built
component
in this particular library which you can
use in your own project let me show you
by click clicking get started over here
i'm going to close this project which
was already open
so yeah we can install this by using npm
install
material ui core so we're gonna install
this as well let me see if our app has
installed
no it's still getting installed let's
just wait for that
so it also provides this material ui
icons
so uh this let's just leave this for
later i'm going to show you how you can
use this library now
let's go to the components and let's go
to
button all right you can see
we have different different types of
buttons over here so you these are
pre-built buttons in the material ui
library you can just
straight up import them by just typing
one line
when you type this line this button will
be imported if you change the color to
primary
this button will be imported so yeah
this is an amazing library
and you might be thinking there might be
other libraries as well yes there
are there's one library called react
bootstrap
i use this library all the time but i
decided to use this material ui library
because it's really easy to work on
light and dark feature as well and
you'll also get to explore something new
in react
so yeah bootstrap is really you know
mainstream type of library but material
ui is
making its uh place in the market so
yeah materializing a really good
library so what are we going to use from
this material library we're going to use
something called
text field is it text
let me tap yeah text field over there so
texture we're going to use this
component
right here so what it's going to do it's
going to provide us a pre-built
input component where we can search our
particular word
we're going to use that and we're going
to use this select
where to go yeah here it is we're gonna
use this select component as well
right so let's check if our app has
initialized successfully or not
yes it has initialized successfully let
me just switch to this
by typing cd word hunt or what you can
do is go to file
open folder and just go to your
particular folder
in my case this folder and select this
folder
and here it is it has opened that
particular folder in a separate
window so let's go to this and we're
gonna
first of all installed material ui
so yeah let's go over here where was
that particular line
let's go to installation and copy this
line over here copy
and paste it over here so it's going to
take a little bit of time to install
material ui because material is a huge
library
so it just takes a little bit of time so
once it's installed i'll be back
one eternity later all right finally our
material ui library has installed
successfully
so what we're gonna do now with our
react app is that we're gonna
get rid of the useless files that we
don't need right now
so let's just delete these files these
four files over here
no we don't need these files at all but
first of all let me just run this app
for the first time and i'm going to show
you how this looks
when it runs for the first time
so here it is this is our react app
successfully started
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
just dock it right over here
and i'm going to delete these files as i
mentioned earlier
so let's just delete these four files
and let's go to and
you can see this app is now going to
complain because it's
it was using those files somewhere so
let's just uh
check so logo was being used over here
we don't need it
we're just gonna get rid of all of this
information inside of this file over
here
we're going to index js we're going to
remove this
we're going to remove this and that's
pretty much it let's go to our app.js
and run hello world
hello world yep
there you go hello world but it but it's
in the center because i think we haven't
removed these styles yet
let's remove all of these styles in the
app.js we're not going to touch the
index css or index.js right now
because we don't need right now or
anywhere anytime
because we don't need to do anything
with them so yeah
the hello world has been successfully
printed over here
all right so what uh what are we going
to do first
so let's just uh import our api
in our app real quick let's go to our
api website
was that dictionary api
let me just check yeah there it is
google dictionary api we're gonna need
this particular link
but how are we going to fetch this link
we're going to use a package
called axios so we're going to need to
install that package
so i'm going to open another terminal
over here
i'm going to go npm i
axios
and here we go axios has been
successfully installed
so what are we going to do now we're
going to create a function
let's call this function dictionary api
just a second yeah we're going to call
this function
dictionary api
we're going to create an arrow function
over here and also since we are fetching
the api we need to make this function
async
we need to make this an asynchronous
functions and we are going to type
try cache over here to catch
if any error ever occurs in our app so
i'm going to just log this error right
here
and inside of the try block what we're
going to do first of all let me close
this terminal over here
so yeah right back in our main terminal
so yeah what are we going to do in this
dry block we're going to fetch that api
so const let's type data
equals a weight so we need this await
keyword
inside of this async function otherwise
it's going to give us error
so axios dot get
so let's copy the link from the website
this is the link let's copy this link
over here
all right you see you can see there's
some language code let's just provide is
by default an
english word uh sorry
english keyword whatever so for word i'm
just gonna give it let's just give it
plain
all right so also we're going to need to
call this function somewhere
so where are we going to call this
function we're going to use something
called use effect
use effect so what is use effect all
about let me
clear it up use it
use effect is when you keep these
brackets empty over here
use effect is called whenever your
component is first time rendered
but if you keep anything inside of these
brackets or those are called
dependencies then what it's going to do
it's going to
be called every time those variables are
going to change
you're going to know uh along the way
so i'm going to call this dictionary api
inside of this use effect
let's see what happens use effect is not
defined obviously because we haven't
imported use effect here so i'm going to
import
use effect whoops what just happened
use effect from react
yup it's not going to give me any error
now yep
data is assigned a value but never used
obviously we have called this data
variable but we haven't used it
let's just log this let's see what we
get in this api
i'm going to log this over here and go
to our browser
and go to our app and you can see our
app is empty currently
let's just print dictionary
yeah that's all yep
dictionaries over there so let's check
the console real quick
what do we get inside our console
so we get we're getting this data we're
getting config data headers etc we're
just going to need this data array over
here
so inside of this each of this array
there's a different meaning for this
word called
plane so let's go to inside let's go
inside of one uh
item and inside of one item we can see
there are two
sections first is meaning and the other
one is phonetics
so for inside of phonetics we're getting
this link
clean yep that's the pronunciation for
this particular word
so we're gonna use that later first of
all we need to uh
use this meanings uh item inside of this
array item
so let's go to the meaning item we can
see another array objects
so in each inside of each of these
objects we have a definition
we have example and we have synonyms for
that particular word
so yeah this is how this api is gonna
work
so let's just use it so uh first of all
what do we need
we're gonna go inside of this and take
this data
so for that for uh using that data and
storing it somewhere else
we're gonna create something called a
state in react
we're gonna type use state oops
use state enter you can see it
has given us this code and we're gonna
name this
meanings and since it's going to be in
an
array so we're going to give this an
empty array to begin with
this part right here contains the
initial uh state of this particular
state and this is going to be the
function
which we're going to use to change the
state and this is going to be an actual
variable
let me show you now it's going to
complain because we haven't imported the
use state yet
so let's just import use state
from react
all right so we're going to import all
of this data inside of that
set meanings so let's just
enter and set with one second
yeah set meetings and inside of set
meanings we're gonna type data oops
data dot data
yep and let's just log this meanings
i'm gonna go down here and log
this meanings yeah
let's check our browser let's refresh
this page for once
and you can see we're getting the only
the data part of that
api
so there you go so we need these
meanings uh
uh array so let's just see what are we
going to do next
so first of all what we need to do is we
need to create
another state
for our word
it's going to be empty by default
let's start by creating the header
section of our app
first of all we're going to go to
material ui again
i'm going to introduce you to something
called container in material ui
so this container helps a lot in making
your app responsive
whenever the screen size of your app
changes it's going to adapt
to that particular size let me show you
all real quick
so inside of this app div
where i'm gonna go and write is
container this container tag and you can
see vs code has automatically imported
this container
if you go and press ctrl space
it's going to show you the suggestions
and you can click on the particular
station to automatically import that
and i'm going to give this container a
max width
of medium md you can go through all
of this max with medium small inside of
this
uh documentation of material ui you can
see they have given yeah this is small
size and etc
etc etc now we'll see what happens to
our app let's just type
dictionary
let's see what happens all right let me
close this terminal
and you can see yeah dictionary has been
aligned to the center
to the very center and you can see when
i'm resizing this window
you can see it's adapting to that
particular the container is helping our
screen to adapt to the screen size
so this is how container helps us out
let me give this a few styles as well
i'm going to provide it some inline
styles with the height
of 100 viewport
and the background color
uh background color where it is yeah
it's over here i'm gonna give it
hash two eight two c
three four let's see how that looks
yup that's looking good but our
dictionary has been hidden
so i'm gonna give it a color as well so
color
it's going to be white
yep that's pretty much it
looks pretty alright so we're gonna give
a few styles to our container as well
so as you all might be aware of flexbox
what flexbox is all about in css
we're gonna we're gonna give it a style
of
display so that all of the items are
aligned from top to bottom
we're going to give it flex direction
column
here we go and we're going to give it a
height
of 100 vh
and the justify content okay i'm not
gonna give it right now i'm gonna show
you all later why
that's useful to us so first of all let
me just work on this header part over
here where
our heading and our search and our
select box is going to lie
all right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to go to src
and create a new folder called
components
and inside of this component i'm going
to create a new file
or a new folder called header
now inside of this header uh folder
we're going to create a new file called
header
dot js and another file
for css as well header dot css
so let's go to header.js i'm going to
show you a shortcut
r a f c e if you go
and type this and press enter it's going
to give you a boilerplate code for a
basic react function
so let's create this header component
real quick
first of all i'm just gonna go and type
header
or i'm gonna use let's say a title over
here
i'm gonna give it a span tag
give it a class name of
title i'm gonna write word
hunt yup that looks good and let's just
give this a class name as well
of header yeah that looks good
let's just import this inside of our
app.js let me get rid of this dictionary
over here
and i'm going to type header now you can
see it's giving us auto import
suggestion so we're going to click on
that
and you can see header has been
automatically imported over here
so we're going to make this self closing
tag and let's see if it has rendered or
not
here we go word hunt has been rendered
so i'm just style this word hunt real
quick
i'm gonna go to header header.css
but first of all we need to import this
css file inside of this header
how are we going to do that we're going
to type import
dot slash dot means current directory
slash
header dot css
oops yeah that looks good
now we're gonna have to provide this
title some styling
let's just provide this title a little
bit of styling
let's just say font size of
seven viewport with viewport width is
the width of the screen
that you are currently on on your phone
or your on your computer it's that
particular width
and i'm gonna type text transform
to uppercase so that it's capital
and i'm gonna give it font family first
of all
let's just not give it font family now
let's just check this
okay it's looking good but it's looking
kind of ugly
so we want this to be a little bit of
pretty so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
go to google
google sorry google i'm gonna type uh
monsterat
font if i'm not wrong with the spelling
yeah
monsterat so we need this monstered font
over here
i'm going to go over here 100 select
this style
and go to import and i'm going to take
this
font over here i'm going to copy this
and i'm going to go back to our
this text editor and gonna go to
index.css
just at the right at the top i'm gonna
paste this font style
now let's see what happens if we type
font
family we're gonna need
let me type correct spelling m-o-n
e-s-e-r-r-a-t
yep correct and sans
serif
let's go and check oh it doesn't work
why though hopefully i
haven't put the wrong spelling over here
maybe i did yes i did
okay now let's see yeah it looks really
good
so one piece of advice for you all if
you're gonna make the
word a little bit bigger the heading
little bit bigger just
reduce its font weight so it's gonna
look pretty
these are some of the design you know
tips for you all
so yeah it looks good
so what do we need uh other than this
heading inside
of our header we're going to need the
text component
as you all know so i'm going to create
another div over here
all right i'm going to give class name
of this div
as inputs
yep also i think we need to style our
header as well
little bit i'm gonna bring in the styles
for our header
so what i'm gonna do over here what what
am i doing over here so i'm
providing is a display of flex align
items to the center and justify content
of space evenly so what it's going to do
let me show you all
so let's have uh so i've created this
div let me just say anything hello
if you go back over here you can see
it's aligning from top to bottom
this is happening because of this
flex direction column we have set the
display to flex flash selection column
and we're setting this justify content
space evenly so it's going to
have an even space between them it's
going to have the height of 35 viewport
height
if i increase this to let's say 50
viewport height
see you can see the height has been
increased
so we want this 35 viewport height you
can see there's a space between
these components
so and where is going to be 100 so these
are all the styles
i'm not going to go too in depth in the
css because it's a react
project not the css project so yeah bear
with me
so all right so inside of inputs what do
we need now
we're gonna need a text field so let's
go to our browser real quick
to material ui let's go to the text
field
text field whoops
there we go we're going to need this
standard text field so i'm going to copy
this up
and copy this right here and go to our
text editor
i'm going to i'm going to paste this
over here
and you can see it's going to give us
error because the text field we haven't
imported a text field yet so
i'm going to go over here ctrl space
it's gonna show me suggestion i'm gonna
click over here
and you can see text field has been
imported so yeah vs code helps a lot
while coding
okay it's dark right now you can see
because it the background is also dark
and the
component is also dark so it's not
working out so what do we need to do
over here
we're going to import a dark theme over
here
where do we find this dark theme and
we're going to go to material ui we're
going to search
dark mode here we go
and i'm just gonna copy this up this one
or another one let me check no not this
one
we're gonna copy
yeah i think i'm going to copy that one
yeah we're going to make a little bit of
changes to this one
so here's the dark theme it's going to
complain because we haven't imported
create mui theme
let's create import that one as well
so type is dark so i'm gonna just what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna copy the name
and go inside of this and import
something
called theme provider so theme provider
allows us to pro
you know apply themes to the material ui
components
i'm going to go over here theme so i've
auto imported this
by typing ctrl space you can see it has
been auto imported
i'm going to go over here type theme
equals
dark theme now let's check our component
real quick
has it improved yes it has but still you
can see
when i click over here it goes a little
bit of dark blue so we don't want that
so what are we going to do over here
inside of the
palette we're going to provide it a
primary color
primary of main
it's going to be
hash fff
also comma is needed over here i think
this should work
here we go when we click on it it's
gonna go active with a white color
so yeah we have imported our dark theme
over here
what do we need other than this we're
gonna need a select component
let's find our select component
let me go back to the text field yep let
me scroll
down to here this is what we need
all right okay whoops yeah i'm gonna
click over here
you can see it's provided us a ton of
code over here
so what do we need we need the first one
right yeah we need the first one
i'm gonna go and copy this one
this text field over here from here
to here let's copy it up
and paste it over here it's going to
complain because it's missing a lot of
things first of all this
text field is oh yeah that's imported
we're gonna need this menu item
i'm gonna go ctrl space and press enter
so my new item is important
but you can see this currency and handle
change these are all
there are they just they are not present
in the r file you can see currency
handle change currencies
so what are we going to need this select
for first of all we're going to need
this select for
our countries let me just remove this
remove this
and this map function as well um
yeah we're gonna use that later
yeah inside of the menu item i'm gonna
type
let's say english i'm gonna remove this
key and values as well
let's see if it works or not it does
yep you can see but it has only one
component
so what do we need to do we need to
import all of these
languages so what i have done for you
i've already created a file
over here let me just go to text editor
and create
another folder with the name of data
and i'm going to go and create a new
file
called category
category dot js
yeah category.js inside of this category
i'm gonna
go and provide this particular data so
if you want this particular data what do
you need to do
i'm gonna provide link in the
description to my github repo
you're gonna go to my github repo
you're gonna go to this particular
github repo you're gonna go to src
to the data to the category.js you're
gonna copy
this file i'm going to copy this inside
of your code so what it's just going to
do
is it's providing the value and the
label
it's just in the documentation of that
api you can create it yourself or you
can copy it from my github
so i've created this category.js let's
save it
and inside of our header.js i'm going to
import this up
right here import category
from i'm gonna go one step backwards
another step backwards and inside of the
data
we're gonna need category here we go
so we need this category variable right
here so we're gonna uh
we're gonna map through this inside of
this
menu item so what i'm gonna do now
this and category
dot map i'm gonna go
and loop through this i'm gonna provide
this menu item inside of it
and let's give this a name or variable
name
let's give it the name of option
and inside of this we're gonna go and
type
option dot value because we want the
value to be inside of our
select box let's see if it works or not
yes it does but we need to provide
it a key and value as well so let's go
over here
and have this key i'm going to type
option dot
value sorry option dot label
and the value will be
option dot label
let's save this real quick and let's
check it out
still the same what do we need to do now
we need to provide a value to over here
as well
so we had earlier created a state for
this i guess so we haven't created a
state
so let's just create a state called
category
so impossible oops what am i doing
use state category
yeah that looks fine i'm gonna provide a
default value of
english yep
we need to bring both of these things to
that header component how are we going
to do that
we're going to go over here to the
header component i'm going to do
this we're going to send this as a prop
the category
and the set category as well
yeah so we're going to go inside of our
header
and we're going to receive these both
over here by doing destructuring by
typing curly braces
and enter and category
yeah both of these are over here
let me just rename this to categories
categories so we don't get confused
between this
and this so categories
yep that's fine all right so what's the
value it's going to be
value is going to be category
and on change what it's going to do
it's on change it's going to set that
particular category on that thing
so on change
we're gonna have a event set
category e dot target
dot value let's save this and check this
out
hopefully it should display a language
first yes it's displaying english
over here all right let's make this
thing work
it's displaying standard currently we're
gonna also have to
name that one as well so we're just not
gonna need this
id over here in place of label we're
gonna type
search uh word
and we're going to give it a class name
of search
oops i'm doing this in the wrong place
it's supposed to be over here
both of these things are supposed to be
over here
that was the select one so inside of the
select one what we're going to do we're
going to label it
language and we don't need this helper
text right here
let's remove that
okay all right so inside of this one
we need to bring our word state that we
created
let me show you all where is it
yep word and set word i'm gonna take
both of these
and send it to header
so word equals
word and set word
equals set word there's not going to be
any commas over here
so yeah we have sent this let's just
receive them
over here word and
set word
yes i'm going to give this a value
of word
and on change what's going to happen on
change it's going to change that
set word so e
set word e dot target
dot value let's see this thing in action
what i'm going to do over here
is i'm going to check if is there
anything in word
i'm going to type like this in curly
braces
is there anything in word question mark
if there's anything in word we're gonna
render word
otherwise what we're gonna do we're
gonna rendered
word hunt
it's gonna update it in real time
let's check it out let's type over here
hello you can see
it's working absolutely fine whenever
we're changing it
it's calling this on change function to
change this state
and providing this particular value to
this particular box
and changing this if there's nothing
inside of it it's not going to change if
there's anything
yep it's working fine all right
i see a problem over here why is this
compressed to so little because
it doesn't have a width over here and
neither does this thing over here
here have a width so let's see what i'm
gonna do
i'm gonna give it a class name of search
i'm gonna
give this a class name let's give it a
class name
of select yeah
that's fine now i'm gonna go to
header.css
first of all i need to provide inputs a
little bit of styling
also we need to uh make sure of one
thing over here i'm gonna make these two
responsive as well
because when you go over here when you
make this smaller
you can see word hunt becomes a little
too much tiny
so we want this to look a little bit off
better
than that so we're gonna make it
responsive so we're gonna make it
responsive by using media queries
so at media oops
media we're going to type
max width if the max width is lesser
than 900 pixels what's gonna happen
it's gonna do is dot header
it's gonna make header justify content
space evenly and
height is gonna be 25 years we're gonna
decrease our height a little bit
second thing what we're going to do is
in the title
we're going to increase the font size of
this word hunt
so font size of let's say 11
vh
whoops what just happened over here
i think i need to provide it a little
bit more of a height
let me check no it's fine
uh let's see if i go over here and
provide styling to inputs
i think i need to install the inputs
first
i'm going to provide it a width of 100
percent
and i'm going to provide a display of
flex and justify content i'm going to
provide it a space
between these space around
so you can see it has a space between of
these
let's check this i think i need to make
it uh
with the width of 100 if i'm not wrong
but i have provided the width of 100
then what's wrong over here this is
correct
and just if i continue center
i'll i'm sorry it's space evenly i don't
think i need to provide it over here
once again so i'm going to remove that
everything looks fine
let's figure it out later
for now what i'm gonna do okay that's
the problem
i've given it v h i need to give it vw
yeah that was the problem because it was
in respect to the height of the screen
okay that was the problem so yeah it
looks good now
you can see it doesn't get shrinked too
much
when responsive so yeah we're talking
about this
let's me give it a little bit of weight
over here
first of all i'm gonna style this input
box over here
so search
search is going to have width of 43
percent
and same is going to be for select as
well so i'm gonna do is
comma dot select
both of these classes are going to have
43 percent yep that looks pretty
you can see looks really good if you
provide anything it's going to change
the state
so here we go we are done with our
header
let's go to our app.js again let's see
if
anything left in our header over here i
don't think we have anything left in the
header
all right one more thing i think i'm
gonna do is whenever we type
we're gonna search a text let's say if i
search plain
and if i change the category so what it
should do it should clear this out
and the meanings part as well the
meaning state as well
so what i'm gonna do i'm gonna create
another function over here
const handle change
so we're going to call this function
right here
uh this text field i'm going to call
this function right here
and inside of this since it's sending
us this e.target.value we're going to
receive it over here
what this value has it value has the
language
i'm going to provide this language to
set
category
language should work still the same and
the set word should be empty now
let's try this out if i change our
category yep it's empty if i type
anything
change it yeah it's empty it's working
great
all right one more thing that we need to
do that we have left out
is how do we change our api when we
change this
box or this particular select box
so we're going to use backticks over
here
remove these normal string tags i'm
going to use the
backtick and go to
language part we're going to type dollar
sign and this curly braces
and i'm going to type category
and it's our instead of this word
and then we're gonna do the same thing
and type word
great so let's check if our
api is responding to that
oops what just happened yeah
let's go to our console
yeah it's showing an error because
there's nothing inside of it so let's
just type hello
and you can see yep
what why is it still showing word okay
because
i think i have no it's i haven't
provided it
it's fine looks fine let's just reload
this page once again
and type hello
okay react hooks has a missing
dependency of course
because we need to call this api every
time we change
our world or category so we're going to
provide it word
and category so that is what's going to
happen that
is what was wrong in the previous one
every time we change this word let's say
hello
it's going to call the api again you can
see
it's calling the api and you can see
it's providing us with the meaning and
everything that we need
to work with yep that's great
that is what we need so let's just start
working on this
we're gonna remove this console.log let
me
over here we're gonna work on this below
part
so what i'm gonna do i'm gonna create
another component for that
i'm gonna go over here instead of our
components we're gonna create a new
folder
called let's say definitions
i'm going to make it a capital it's very
important
not the folder but the file that you
create it should be in the capital
dot js and another file for css
i think i have created it inside of the
header so i'm gonna take it out of the
header
yeah now it's fine so our definition.js
let's go and type
rafce and get the boilerplate code
let's just type hello
and i'm gonna import it first of all let
me just create a css file for it as well
definitions dot css and import that css
file inside of here
import dot slash definitions
dot css oops yeah
let's just import these definitions in
our app.js
below this header i'm going to type
definitions
yes let's see if it's
auto imported yes it has
let's go to our app and check yes hello
is printed over here successfully
great so what do we need to create
inside of the definitions
we need to create a box as i showed you
earlier inside of that
we're going to render all of our
meanings for this particular
you know word and the category so let's
see what are all the things that we need
to send
to the the definition
so i think we're going to need to send
this word and
the category and no
yeah we're going to need to send this
word and the meanings
because the category is not needed over
there because category is changing the
api that's all it it's doing
so we're going to send the word let's
first of all send
the word
and we're going to send the meanings
state
all right and we're going to set the
category as well
let's see if we need that or not
category
let's just close the useless folders
yeah let's go back to the definition and
receive all of that
over here word
category and
meanings
all right let's save this
also i'm gonna render this definitions
only when there's something inside of
that meanings
you know if there's nothing inside of
the state then we don't need to see
anything over here
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
provide it in curly braces
i'm gonna say meanings
and this so there's something inside of
the meanings only then the definitions
will be rendered
let's go inside of the definitions and
let's see
so first of all we're going to need an
audio component as well but
i'm going to leave that audio component
for the later
so let's just start by typing
if there's anything inside of the word
so
so if if there's nothing inside of the
world first of all
what it's going to render it's going to
render a span tag
a span tag with the class name of
let's say sub title oops
title and it's gonna say start
by typing a word
in search
yeah but if there's something inside of
the word
what it's gonna render it's gonna render
this
something else let's say something
there's something over here oops i'm
just gonna do this
yeah let's see
yeah start by typing a word insert let
me just style it
a little bit i'm gonna provide this div
a class name of
let's say meanings
or meanings we have imported our css all
as well
let's just style both of these first
so that we're done with that
i'm gonna go and type meanings
what are we gonna do first of all we
need a border as i displayed earlier
but first of all i'm gonna do is gonna
type display
flex we're gonna we're gonna need to
make it flex box and we need
everything to be aligned from top to
bottom
from top to bottom we're gonna do flex
uh direction as column
and yeah and we're gonna do
when there's a lot of item being
displayed over here we're gonna have to
do overflow y as a scroll
overflow y as scroll
you know what i'm thinking let's just
apply this style later
so that wait something's wrong no
so that you have something to see first
of all i'm gonna import something
inside of instead of this something
written over here
so yeah first of all let me demonstrate
if it's working or not
if i have anything you can see there's
something printed if it's nothing it's
gonna say start by having a word in
search
let's just style this subtitle i'm gonna
go
and style this subtitle only
for now sub title
i'm gonna give it a font size a similar
font size that we provided
earlier five viewport width and
the font family is going to be the same
monsterat let me just copy it so uh that
i don't make any spelling mistake this
time
yep yeah that looks good
it's gonna be font size five uh vh
and what i'm thinking
no yeah that's fine anyway so yeah
what we're going to do we are going to
render this meanings instead of
this thing so let's go over here
i'm gonna type meanings i'm gonna map
through this
and map i'm gonna
give it a word mean
and just do that
let's just log it let's see what do we
get inside of it
i mean is there something wrong yeah
semicolon
let's see what do we get
if i type anything plain
whoa you can see we get a lot of things
over here we get an
array of word and the phonetics and
okay that's not the final word that this
is the final word we're getting meanings
and the phonetics so we need to
uh array through this meanings
again i'm gonna remove this now
all right so what i'm gonna do is
oh get out of here yeah mean dot
meanings dot
map i'm gonna name this variable as item
let's see what's inside of it let's log
it
uh item
yeah let's log this real quick and first
of all i need to remove this
log from here so it doesn't create some
confusion
let me just close this terminal yeah
make some space
yeah let's see what we get let me
refresh this over here
i'm gonna type plane
there we go we can see a lot of things
over here we can see our definitions
so now we need to end uh you know a map
through this definitions
so we get each each of the definitions
and the other thing has to be synonyms
and examples okay it doesn't have over
here
it's going to be somewhere right here
definitions
what's going on
let me just check this
it has to be inside of this somewhere
it's gonna be somewhere inside of this
parts of speech parts of speech
definitions
yeah you can see example and this one as
one extra thing it's going to be synonym
we're going to make this example in
synonym as optional because you can see
somewhere it's appearing somewhere it's
not appearing
so we're going to make that optional so
let's go back to our code
let's just remove this
inside of it i think i removed something
else
did i do something wrong no
i'm supposed to remove this yes
so inside of this so we have our item
so with our item let me shift it back
over here
with our item what what are we going to
do we need definitions
we're going to map through definition i
know this is a lot of mapping over here
this is mapping l so i'm going to do is
definite item.definitions.map
and let's give it the variable name at
def
all right now we need to create a div
oops div
yeah there's our div and i'm gonna
give it a class name of
single meaning or single mean
whatever you want to call it i'm gonna
give it a style
little bit of styling i'm giving gonna
give it a background color
the single component is gonna have a
background color of
white let's see and what else do we need
i'm gonna give it since it's white i'm
gonna make the content as black
color black let's see if i type anything
inside of this
let's print our definition first so i'm
gonna
print the definition in bold so def
dot definition
let's check all right here we go
these are the different different
definitions that we're getting from the
api
for the word plane if i type ball
here we go we're getting different
different meanings for the ball
so we did we just don't need uh just the
definitions we're gonna need
the examples as well so i'm going to
create a line
between both of these
i'm going to give it a style of
background color
of black
and the width
not the width of
100 let's say
i hope it's going to create a little bit
of separation yep it does
you can see this overflow is also over
here i'm going to hide it in a while
so we have got this hr now
all right now these optional parts def
dot
example if there's an example then what
are we going to print
this we're going to create a span tag
instead of the span tag first of all we
need to type example
so we're going to make the example as
bold example
all right and we're gonna print def
dot example let's check that out
okay this is not appropriate it was
having some shady meanings
yeah so yeah you can see example
definition
uh definition example yeah there you go
so what else do we need
we need the synonyms
right below the example i'm going to
type def
dot synonym
if the synonym exists synonym s also is
going to be there
so if the synonym exists what are we
going to do we're going to
do the same thing that we did over here
we're going to copy this
i'm going to paste it over here i'm just
going to change the synonyms
and def dot synonyms
synonyms since there are many synonyms
so i'm gonna do
again do a map through the synonyms
s and i'm gonna do with the back tick
i'm gonna do is this
i'm gonna print s and comma let's see
how that looks
you can see synonyms but it looks kind
of ugly you know it's in the same line
so we need to do what we need to uh do
is we're gonna have this in
all on this in different lines so first
of all
let's just uh style the outer container
first
i'm gonna style this mix container first
right
i'm gonna go to definitions.css and
let's continue from here
i'm gonna type this ugly scroll bar i
need to make it a
little bit smaller so i'm going to type
scroll
with i think yup scroll bar with i'm
going to give it thin
now you can see our scroll bar is
looking much
better you can see in the side scroll
bar is thinner
i'm gonna give it a height of
55 viewport height and the border
get a border of 10 pixels 10 pixels of
solid and i have a color over here
i'm gonna copy this you can just copy
this color over here you can just
uh experiment with these colors by
clicking over here and just select a
color i've
chosen this color it was looking good
and gonna give it a border
radius of 10 pixels let's see how far it
looks
okay it's not very good i think i need
to give it some padding
so i'm gonna give it a padding
in top and bot i'm going to give it 10
pixels and
and left and right i'm going to give it
20 pixels
and the overflow x will be hidden we
don't want the bottom bar
overflow x will be hidden
yes we just need this bar also we need
to create some separations between this
so now i'm gonna provide that
style but let me just check if it's
responsive right now
so if you can see if we make it smaller
it has a little bit of gap
between this i mean below this we're
gonna make it a little bit higher height
when it's smaller so i'm gonna do is
media query
max width of
900 pixels
let's do is meanings
yep meanings and i'm going to give it a
height
of 60 viewport height
yeah looks much better
and overflow
see why am i leaving a little bit of
space over here because we're gonna have
a component
at the top which is going to be
responsible for switching our themes
so i'm just leaving the space for that
overflow x is going to be hidden
and overflow is going to be
scroll yeah
better so in this single meaning
component
let me just just get back to this and
this single meaning component
we need to style this div as well you
know each of these
divs we need to style this as well
i'm going to go over here
i'm going to type display flex
the moment i type this you can see it's
just all horizontal and just looks
really ugly so i'm gonna type flex
direction as column yep that's
a lot better i'm gonna give it
a border radius
of let's say 10 pixels let's try if it
looks good
yeah it's looking better let's just
create a spacing between them by padding
of 10 pixels of top and bottom and left
and right it's going to be 20 pixels
yep okay four spaces between now i need
the margin
what i just need the top and bottom
spacing and left and right is going to
be zero
yeah that's much better you can see
so we're halfway through of our
dictionary app
let's see if our hindi works or not i'm
gonna type my name
yeah it looks it's working man
great tap yourself in the back
you've done a good job anyway
putting the cringe aside so what are we
going to do next
we're going to create a theme switcher
component
do we need this category now i don't
think we need it
let me just check i think we're gonna
need this
in our audio component yes
i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is while
creating the audio component if the
category is english only then we're
gonna print the audio component because
uh audio component is not available in
the other languages so just create that
real quick so meanings
it's only available in the first item of
this meanings array
so i'm going to type if the meanings
first item
is available and
if there's something inside of the word
if this is true
and third thing that needs to be true is
if there's something inside of cano
not something inside of i mean if it's
english
if the category is english if these
three conditions are true
then only it's going to go and render
our app sorry audio component
i'm going to go inside of here and now
i'm going to render the audio component
all right if the audio component not
supported i'm gonna type your
browser doesn't
what doesn't
support audio element
that's better always have to give some
message or some [ __ ] like that
sorry yeah so inside of this style
we're going to name background color
we're going to give is a background
color of
hash ff which is white
and the border radius
of 10. let's see if it's
rendering or not of course it's not
random because we haven't typed anything
still doesn't render okay we haven't
prohibited it obviously we haven't
provided it the
src that's provided the src
so src will be inside of our meanings
the first element of our meaning that's
why i included the first element
inside the phonetics as i showed you
earlier
phonetics
and sorry phonetics inside of the first
element of the phonetics
uh so okay sometimes what happens is the
phonetics is also missing so i'm gonna
uh test if the phonetics is present or
not so if phonetics is there
it's present then we're gonna type the
same thing
again and inside of this there's
something
called audio
and also i'm going to provide it control
so we have the controls to pause and
play the audio etcetera
now here we go plane there you have it
you have the audio component
there's your there are your controls to
increase the audio or decrease the audio
etc so yeah here's the audio component
so what's the last thing that we need to
do we need to create
it a theme switcher component we need to
create a theme switcher component over
here
all right let's go back to our app.js
and what i'm gonna do first of all i'm
gonna go back to this material ui
i'm gonna import something called switch
we need because obviously
we're gonna need a switch to switch the
theme so these are the normal
switches with secondary primary and
control etcetera so we we're gonna need
a switch which
from uh which we're gonna change its
color so
here's the custom color component i'm
gonna copy this up
i'm gonna go over here i'm gonna copy
this particular
component this is the component you can
go through the documentation you will
also
understand what's going on over here so
i'm going to copy this up
let's go and ctrl c i've copied it up
so inside of our app.js i'm gonna paste
it
right over here and it's gonna complain
because some things are not imported
like with styles
let's import the width styles there's
something else yeah the purple color but
we don't need a purple color
we're gonna replace it with gray color
so enter you can see gray color has also
been imported
switch is not defined yep switch
we also need to import the switch we
imported the switch
and hopefully it's gonna work but it's
not gonna show over here
until we render it down in our app
so let me just create a little bit of
spacing over here
it works face over there so i'm just
gonna render it
right over no
right over here inside of our container
yeah
just above the header so what i'm going
to do
is i'm going to give it another div
because we're going to make this div as
absolute so that this
the position of this div is always the
top right corner
i'm going to make this absolute and the
style is going to be
position as
absolute and
the top will be zero let me just write
something inside of this let's say
theme
you'll see yeah theme appears over here
we're gonna
make it right with let's say
15.
yeah that's a sweet spot and we're going
to provide a little bit of padding on
the top
of 10. great
all right now we need to use this purple
switch
it still has the name of purple switch
let me just change the name of
let's say theme
changer
i hope it's not a pre-built component
material ui
let's just call it dark mode
yeah i'm gonna call it dark mode that's
better
so instead of this theme i'm gonna
render the dark mode over here
here we go hopefully it's gonna render
now
yep there we go yes all right so before
this dark mode i need to provide a span
tag
which is gonna say uh
some particular mode let's say for now
let's say it's saying
light mode to switch the light mode you
can just press that
and it's gonna switch to that particular
mode
so also inside of this dark mode when we
need to provide few of the components
let's provide checked
c h e k e d yeah
checked equals we're going to provide a
particular state inside of it so we need
to uh
create a state for checked just like a
normal switch in html it's just going to
work just like that
we're gonna provide a value and on
change as well
so let's quickly create a state for our
dark mode and light mode i'm gonna go
create a use state
i'm gonna call it light mode
i should have called that component
light mode as well but anyway
so light mode by default is gonna be
false
all right because you can see uh we're
gonna
load this app in dark mode because our
eyes are useful
we don't want to get blind by light mode
so a light mode
over here and on change it's just gonna
flip the switch so what i'm going to do
is
set light mode and
the opposite of whatever the current
value is
so opposite of light mode yes
there we go i think we need to uh
provide the
styling to this thing the flex styling
to this thing
so i'm gonna go inside of our
inside over here i think i'm gonna have
to provide this a little bit of styling
or maybe our container flex direction
column
height hundred vh yes we haven't
provided the justify content evenly yeah
justify content space evenly
space evenly now you'll see
much prettier now
if you have any confusion in the code
you just you can just go to my github
repo the link is provided in the
description
to see all of the code changes if you
have any confusion
i said that twice yes uh yeah so where
was
i i was over here yeah dark mode
so what i'm going to do if a person
switches to light mode
this let this text should also change
first of all let's take care of that
i'm going to provide it a javascript tag
over here
and let's say light mode if light mode
is turned on
then it's gonna render dark otherwise
it's gonna render light
let's see if that works or not
by default it's dark mode so i'm gonna
turn it on see it's gonna show dark mode
if i turn it off light all right so
finally here's the moment of truth how
do we implement this feature
so what do we need to do is wherever we
have set these colors
we just need to put a condition over
there
so let's start from this place from our
app component i'm gonna make it full
screen
and i'm gonna check let's check
is light mode turned on if yes
then i'm gonna provide it a color of
white
triple f otherwise that color
and the color is also gonna be affected
by this is the light mode turned on
we're going to ask this question again
if it's on then i'm going to provide it
black whoops
i can't type
there we go it's compiling
let's just test this out
whoa works like magic
but we have still some things that we
need to take care of
also we just don't want this just
smacking the flight mode in our face
just we want to provide a little bit of
transition
so that it's soft it looks good we're
going to provide all
0.5 seconds you can just configure this
according to your own and linear
now it's going to be a little bit of
soft
there you go looks much better so i'm
going to
style this as well or where is that
thing
so first of all let me see if there's
anything needs to be changed over here
in respect to dark mode or light mode no
i think we're gonna just send the light
mode
over here in our header as well
so that we can work with this thing
all right and i'm going to set this over
here as well man
whoops not the light theme light
mode whoa apparently i cannot type
light mode equals light mode
i'm going to provide it to that theme
and just go oops
i'm gonna go to our theme now
i mean header now i can't talk i can't
write
i'm so stupid yeah
calm down push it's not a very big
tutorial
light mode see light
i'm just gonna paste it yeah light mode
so over here i'm gonna check is the
light mode
turned on question mark if it's turned
on
i'm gonna provide it a black color hash
zero zero zero otherwise white
i'm gonna check this again is it turned
on
if it is i'm gonna give it a light theme
otherwise oops otherwise dark
yeah let's check this out again
pretty enough but let's type over here
something
see
oh that doesn't looks good we need to
create it a little bit
i just need to give something black
theme or something let's see if there's
something remaining over here
i don't think so so we're going to
provide the same thing to our
definitions component as well
all right um yep light mode
i'm gonna go to which i already have
came over here so i'm what i'm gonna do
over here
let's see uh yeah right here we're gonna
check if the light mode is turned on or
not
question mark is the light mode turned
on so we're gonna provide it a
color of which was our background
three b 5 3
6 0 otherwise white we're going to test
this out again over here is there a
light mode
then we're going to provide it a white
color otherwise
a black color let's check that out
here we go damn that looks
really pretty
really good all right and i think with
this we have
successfully created our app all right
let's just quickly go to netlify
and i'm gonna host this website
so how do we host these websites on
netlify
so i've already hosted this website on
the netlify
already this uh this word hunt
i'm gonna click new site from get and
then click on this
github button over here then i'm gonna
log in so you can see
i've already authorized the github so
it's going to show my repositories
then i'm going to select this react
dictionary
repository where my code lies so after
pushing it to the github
you just need to click on this deploy
site button and this site will be
deployed
and that's all that's all you need to do
and
let's say if you want to change the
domain of your website
what are you going to do you're going to
go to your web app and click on
domain settings click on options edit
site name and you can provide a custom
site name
right here so what i'm gonna do in the
in our next video
i'm gonna make this application a pwa a
progressive web app
so what is a pwa or progressive web app
so pwa allows you to install a
particular web app into your
phone natively what i mean by that is
when you go to that web app into your
phone's browser or desktop browser it's
going to prompt you with an installation
icon
so when you press that installation
prompt it's gonna start installing that
app natively into your phone
so you can use that app just like a
native app into your phone or desktop
so this is an amazing feature of a
progressive web app so let's get started
so as you can see
we are running our dictionary app
currently in our browser and i've opened
this
project file as well so what are we
going to do now
so we're going to go to chrome developer
tools
by clicking on inspect and go to
lighthouse
so what lighthouse allows us to do it's
gonna scan our app and it's gonna tell
us
what are the features that are missing
to make it a progressive web app
so it's gonna in your case it's gonna
show you all of these icons as ticked
so you need to untick all of these icons
except the progressive web app
and click on generate report so it's
going to scan your
website and tell you what are the things
that are missing
to create it a progressive web app so
let's check
all right here we go so these are the
things these are the red
errors are the things that we need to
complete so first of all let's start
from the bottom
so first of all it's asking us that
manifest doesn't have a maskable icon so
we need to create a maskable icon
but first of all what i'm going to do is
you can see that
first of all let's go to the application
tab yeah you can see that this icon has
these react icons
so we don't want this react icons we're
going to change these icons
to our own icon of the app so let's go
to google and search
dictionary icon png
here you go let's go to images and we're
going to have that icon with
in which we have full usage rights let's
go
click over here and let's choose this
icon
i'm going to click on this icon so it's
going to take us to the website and from
here we can
freely download this icon oh we need to
register
let me quickly do that okay so we have
downloaded it icon over here
it's going to be free it's not going to
cost any money
so let's convert this icon into a
favicon
so we're going to go to the browser and
type
png to favicon
let's go to this website
and we need to drag and drop our file
over here so let's take this file
and drop it over here and let's click on
download
so it has provided us with this zip file
let's keep our zip file over here and
extract it
all right here we are so what are the
files that we need
we're gonna need this one okay we're
gonna need all of these
and this one yeah let's
cut this icons over here and we're going
to go to our
yeah over here into public folder and
we're going to paste it over here
and replace the file
and here we have it we have these
favicon files over here we're gonna
remove
both of these files
yeah we don't need them we're gonna
remove them
all right so let's go back to our code
and into our public folder in
index.html we're gonna need to add a few
lines
so right over here you can see there's
an apple touch icon over here so we just
gonna change the href
to something else let's see what was the
name of our file
here's the name of our file apple touch
icon dot png
so apple touch icon.png here we go it
has auto suggested as this name
and the other thing that we need to add
is our favicon icon
so link
short cut
icon all right now we need to give it an
href
so it's gonna be favicon if i'm not
wrong
let me check yeah favicon.ico
yes we need that there we go
what's wrong okay we haven't closed the
tag now we're done
now let's go to our website and check
here you go you can see the icon has
changed
let me just reload this page and go to
inspect
and go to application now we can see
over here you can see our favicon has
changed successfully
now what do we need to do for the step
two is we need to generate a manifest
file
so what is a manifest.json file if you
go to your react app
you can see there is something called
manifest.json it has it favicon.ico
it has the logos different different
logos that do logo files that we deleted
so we're not going to use this we're
going to delete that right here
and i'm going to delete this as well we
don't need these
i'm going to delete those as well
basically everything we're going to
delete it over here
first of all let me generate our you
know manifest
files data so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go to this website
manny fest
generator let's see
here we go here you have it let's give
our app a name
word hunt i'm gonna give it short name
of word hunt
theme color let's say i'm gonna choose
black
all right display mode is going to be
standalone
because we want this to be acting as a
native app so we're gonna do is
stand alone orientation it depends on
your app
if your app supports portrait as well as
landscape you can select any
in my case i'm going to select any so
application scope no nothing to change
over here so here we go
we have this manifest data generated so
i'm going to copy it up
and i'm going to go to our vs code and
paste it over here
comma is needed over there yeah all
right now we need to generate
our icons so how we're going to do that
so earlier we have downloaded that
file where is it yeah word hunt we're
gonna use that to generate our different
different sizes
so there are four sizes that you need to
have generate
first one is 192 x 192 second 256
third 354 and fourth is 512.
let's go to our browser and let's
enter image resizer
yeah let's go to imageresizer.com
all right here we are we're gonna supply
it
our image right here
so first of all what do we need we're
gonna need to generate
192 x192
there we go resize image now
all right here we are let's download
this image
here we go so we're going to go to our
project folder
and we're going to paste it over here so
let's just drag
and drop over here so here it is
now second one also i'm gonna name it
let's name it logo 192.
we're gonna follow this convention all
right let's generate another one
let's take that i'm just gonna generate
for everything then i'm gonna
paste it all together over there
second one is 256 into 256.
let's download that the third one
um yeah
the third one was three eight four into
three eight
four
here we go
final file will be
512 into 512 512
x512 resize that image
all right here we go it has mistakenly
downloaded it twice
i'm going to delete it never mind
all right so we're going to copy all of
these files
to this folder
public folder and then i'm going to name
them
the same way that i named this logo 192
so this one is logo 256.
this one is logo uh 384
and this one was logo
512. here we are all right so we
have all of the icons generated
successfully
all right let's go to our vs code and
let's create our icons
so what we're supposed to do now is this
we're going to enter that so what have i
done over here
let's see
yeah so we're going to provide the src
of wherever the location of icon is i'm
going to remove this
and type logo 192.
same for this one as well logo 256
logo three eight four and lastly
logo five one two now let's save our
application
let's uh save it yeah and let's go to
the chrome
let's refresh this page all right
compile successfully let's go to inspect
and application there we have it we have
all of the icons over here
great and also we need to add a service
worker i'm gonna explain what service
worker it
is later let's go to our lighthouse over
here
let's generate the report and now let's
start working on that
all right first one is that manifest
doesn't have a maskable icon
so what is a maskable icon so maskable
icon is something that when you install
the app in your phone
the icon that is displayed over there in
in your menu
that is what maskable icon is so how do
we generate a maskable icon
so there's a website called maskable.app
i'm going to close both of these i'm
going to go to mask cable
dot app slash editor
here we are so we need to provide it our
first of all we need to provide our icon
or the image
that we need to use so this one i'm
gonna drag
and drop over here so here we are now we
need to make it according to our
you know according to our liking so i'm
gonna do is
let's say rounded rectangle yeah that
looks good i'm gonna
provide it a little bit of padding i'm
gonna shift it a little bit over
here so it looks good i think that's
good
i think that looks fine yeah so i'm just
gonna export it
it has downloaded that let's
go to our public folder and i'm gonna
drag and drop that over here
let's drag and
[Music]
drop over here i'm gonna give it the
name of maskable
masks cable yeah great so now in our
manifest file we need to provide the
location of this maskable
let's go to the manifest.json
and at the top over here i'm going to
open another curly brace
just like the others we need to provide
it src first of all
oops src
so what is going to be the src
maskable the name that we gave maskable
dot png yeah is it here it is
so what's the size size is going to be
196
into 196.
um 196 into
196. here it is
we need to add the type type is going to
be image
slash png
and the purpose purpose
is going to be any maskable here it is
let's save that and let's check
our website let's go over here and
refresh it
i'm going to close it and open into a
new tab
let's go to inspect to
the lighthouse and generate report once
again
all right here you go manifest has a
maskable icon
let's see what else is left right next
thing what do we need to do is does not
redirect http traffic to https
so it's going to be fixed when we deploy
it to netlify since netlify
directs all the traffic to https so it's
not going to be the problem
so let's leave this one for now and the
third one is that
does not register a service worker that
controls page and a start url
so all of these three are linked
together
so we need to provide that let's go over
here where is it
so as you can see we don't have any
service worker file currently
so how do we need to generate the
service worker file
so let's go to a new window
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna open a
folder
let's open a folder right over here
i'm gonna name this folder service
worker something anything doesn't really
matter so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to initialize a new react
app
but it's not going to be the
conventional way what i'm going to do is
i'm going to enter npx
create react app
and what do we need to do yeah
we need to write any any name let's say
my app
and i'm gonna write template
for cra dash template
dash pwa so when you type this
it's going to generate a react app
especially configured for a pwa
application so let's enter
that and let's see what happens
all right here we go it has successfully
initialized a new react app
so what do we need from this react app
we need these two files
serviceworker.js and serviceworker
registration.js
so we're going to select these and copy
these
and copy these into our project
over here into the src folder i'm going
to go and paste it
so we have both of these service worker
files let's go back to that project
and let's go inside of index.js let's
see how these
files are being used so it's being used
over here
and we need to add this line as well so
i'm going to add this line first
let's import that copy and paste into
our index.js file
here we go let's go back and let's copy
this part as well
copy and paste it over here and let's
save that
and let's see the app has compiled
successfully let's go back to our local
host
and i'm going to open this in new tab
again
let's go to inspect and check the
lighthouse
let's enter the report
all right let's see what happened okay
it's still giving the same error
why because because of this when you go
to index
uh sorry service worker there's
something called inside of register you
can see it only
works on a production app so our app is
currently in development so let's build
this app
and let's see if it works or not so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to type
npm run
build so it's going to build our app a
production ready app
all right first of all whoa whoa we
forgot to do this
instead of unregister we need to change
it to register
yes so that it can register our service
worker
so now let's run the build
all right our app has been built
successfully so what does it say
it say you can run this command to run
the production build
but first of all if you if you don't
have the serve what you need to do
you can run npm i sir
dash g when you run this command sorry
not
nom it's npm so when you run this
command
what it's gonna do it's going to install
this command server in your
machine so let's just run this command
now serve
dash s build i'm going to copy it and
run it over here
so it says it is serving on our local
host in our local host 5000 so let's go
to localhost 5000 now
localhost i'm going to change this to
5000
and our app is running let's go to
inspect
and to the lighthouse and let's generate
the report
again
all right here you go these checks
welded the expert
so now you can see it has uh lighten up
this progressive web app icon so all we
need to do
now is does not redirect http traffic to
https
so when you deploy this app to netlify
so what it's gonna do it's gonna
successfully direct all the traffic from
http to https
then it's going to be created as a
progressive web app
so if you don't know how to deploy this
app on netlify you can check
our previous video where where we have
created this dictionary app
so let's check our deployed website now
let's go to word hunt dot netlife.app
this is our deployed website now final
check
or first of all you can see there's one
install button over here
if i click on this install button it's
gonna ask me to install this app
just like i showed you earlier in phone
this is how you can install it on your
desktop let's click on install
and here you go this app has been
installed successfully
here you go our app is right here word
hunt when we click on it
it has installed as a native app in our
pc
and check the final time
let's generate the report and it's going
to show us that
our app is now successfully a pwa
here you go there you have it our
progressive app is working
fine progressive web app is working fine